Karina is with us in Montgomery Alabama
hi Karina how are you hey Dave I'm great
how are you better than I deserve what's
up I'm trying to help my sister her
husband recently passed away just a few
weeks ago and she's trying to keep her
home I don't know if that's going to be
possible in the meantime one of her
friends was talking to her about a HELOC
I had never heard of that I looked it up
and it didn't seem like a good option at
all um to me it looked like she could
get into a lot more trouble yeah passed
away a couple of weeks ago yes sir oh my
goodness I'm so sorry and so how much
does she owe on her home 30,000 not much
that's good news how old is she yes 52
is she working she is working she's in
Tucson I'm here in Alabama she works
part-time as a cashier I have asked her
to if she didn't think it would be a
good idea to get a job where she could
work more hours and she doesn't think
she has marketable skills have any money
no what is the house worth approximately
I'm gonna say 270 275 all right well
here's the thing let's pretend the house
was paid for
I had no debt on it at all I guess you
didn't I guess there's no life insurance
no that's correct
okay even if you live in a $300,000 home
you cannot work part-time as a cashier
and even keep the insurance and taxes
going so she very sadly is going to have
to address her career goals the good
news is she's only 52 really all right
20 years she could be working she could
make millions of dollars
in the next 20 years today she doesn't
feel like that today she feels like an
unskilled Widow and she's scared and so
we've got to help her get past that and
make make her believe that she has real
potential because she does have real
potential that may take a little time
with the grieving process but a HELOC is
a home equity line of credit it's a
second mortgage so you don't go borrow
more money go further in debt when
you're broke and have a very low income
that's going to cause her to lose the
home okay so I want I want her to either
sell the house but I'd prefer she didn't
right now instead I would prefer that
gradually as the waves of grief go away
and as her brain starts to clear the fog
of grief starts to blow off of her brain
that gradually she start to see her
potential get excited dream again think
about taking a class think about working
60 hours a week think about doing
something very very fun you know Mary
Kay started Mary Kay Cosmetics she was
54 Colonel Sanders started Colonel
Sanders fried chicken he was 67 you're
not too old yeah you're not too old
you're not too old she's not too old
matter of fact she's got a lot of
potential next eight years between 52
and 60 could be really lucrative but
she's got to believe that she can do it
like I believe she can do it this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]